Hello and welcome to the fire of learning.
I'm Justin [inaudible] and today we're going to be discussing the political
compass.
There are many charts and graphs used to help plot of political orientation,
but the political compass,
a system which plots or position on a Cartesian coordinate plane is becoming
more and more popular.
So we're going to be talking about how it works and what it represents.
Quick Note,
before we get started,
I understand politics is always a sensitive topic and right now,
political tension may be very high.
So as always,
I'm going to be as impersonal about this as possible and not press my own
opinions in any way or form.
Basically,
if you have no idea at all where I am on the spectrum,
by the end of the video and I've done my job correctly.
All right,
so as I said,
there are many charts people have made to try to organize political orientations
over the years.
Some are more basic,
some are more complex.
The political compass seems to have become popular because it's complex enough
to give appreciable detail and accuracy,
but isn't so complex that it's esoteric.
The exact creators are unknown but its origins land,
www.politicalcompass.org and the website also offers a test that help
individuals place themselves on the coordinate plane.
The test has been criticized as being too limited and having a left wing bias.
Whether or not that's true is you our opinion,
but regardless of whether or not that's true,
the compass itself has expanded beyond the website into mainstream use,
especially on the Internet.
Here's how it works.
The y axis or the up and down has to deal with the authority of the government.
Whether you prefer a hands on government,
Authoritarians,
ISM or a hands off government libertarianism.
On the very bottom you have variance of anarchism and on the top you have
variance of totalitarianism.
People who score on the top half tend to believe that a strong government is
ideal and necessary to a well functioning society.
The higher up you go,
the more decisions you would interest the government with.
People who score in the upper quadrants are more likely to believe that the
government may not always be right or perfect,
but placing major decisions in the hands of informed incompetent leaders is
what's best for everyone.
They're more likely to adhere to philosophy which supports his social contract.
That contract,
which proponents argue is signed by everyone at birth.
The argument made is that the state grants people rights,
freedoms opportunities and other benefits and accomplishments of civilized
society and protects them.
In exchange.
People agree to be loyal to the country and a here to the country's laws and
customs regarding specific issues.
The ideologies at the top tend to favor centralized governments,
strong militaries and police forces,
government intervention in the economy.
Generally more government programs and support.
More laws intended to keep people safe as can probably be inferred.
Ideologies at the very top tend to suggest that society's best when the state is
making all the major decisions.
People who score on the bottom half tend believe that personal liberty and small
government,
our ideal unnecessary to a well functioning society.
The lower you go,
the more decisions you would interest.
Common people with people who score in the lower quadrants are more likely to
believe that though people are not always right or perfect,
their personal freedom is of the highest importance in that everyone taking
personal responsibility for the decisions and making decisions that affect
everyone democratically is what's best for everyone.
They are more likely to adhere to philosophy,
which the course free association,
believing that the state is not what grants rights,
freedoms,
opportunities,
and other benefits and accomplishments of civilized society,
but that these rights are given to everyone by birth and that the job of the
state is to merely do the bare minimum to protect people's freedom regarding
specific issues.
Ideologies at the bottom tend to favor an economy that runs itself naturally.
A small military possibly even relying on militias and believe that society
should have as few laws as possible as Ken probably be inferred.
Ideologies at the very bottom tend to suggest that government is altogether
unnecessary and propose a variety of methods for how society could exist and
function normally without the state.
Around the middle of the two,
people tend to believe in a strong government which is subservient to the will
of the people and probably elected democratically.
Now the x axis and the left and the right.
This is intended to deal with economic position and it's a little bit less
straightforward and the y axis because economics is actually somewhat often
misrepresented as in black and white subject when it is in fact very diverse and
sometimes very complicated.
Essentially the farther left you go,
the more you desire the economy to be run cooperatively,
the farther right you go,
the more you desire for the economy to be run competitively.
Basically on the right you have free market economies and variance of
capitalism.
On the left you have collectivist economies and variants of socialism.
On the very far right,
you have complete free market capitalism.
On the very far left you have complete communism.
People who score on the left tend to be more aligned with the various
philosophies of socialism and it is more appropriate to refer to leftist as
socialists than communists because communism and socialism,
or not necessarily the same thing,
but more precisely coming ism is a kind of socialism and socialism is an
umbrella term for multiple economic ideologies,
which are all intended to give the working class control of what are called the
means of production.
The means of production refers basically to the resources that are given society
or community or whatever has and its ability to use those resources to create
products.
Left scores tend to believe that the economy should be specifically set up to
favor the majority of people and offer a few suggestions on how this should be
done.
Who is responsible for organizing?
Depends on where scores fit on the y axis,
which I'll get to in a moment,
but the intention is roughly for the working class who benefit from this labor
as a group.
Left scores have higher tendencies of that economic burdens or something which
can be overcome.
If the economy of a nation is revised from what they see as a hierarchal top
down to a horizontal equality,
allowing people to focus on more rewarding and fulfilling enterprises and
creating what they see as an ideal society.
Typically left scores tend to believe that you only own what you're actually
using.
Now,
this doesn't mean necessarily that you're expected to be stripped down to the
bare minimum,
but owning,
for example,
a few acres of land or especially a store that you've never even been to would
definitely be frowned upon by leftist.
In standard communist theory.
For example,
the jobs and resources of a given group are divided equally among the workers or
in other words,
promote the phrase from each according to ability to each according to need.
Following this philosophy,
if an area of land rich in iron were discovered,
the iron belongs to everyone in the community.
Everyone shares the burden of extracting it either voluntarily or out of
obligation to the state depending on your y axis.
Again and everyone has an equal right to take with a need from the products.
Right.
Scores tend to believe that the economy should be set up to favor more
unregulated exchange between people of a given group.
There are again,
a few suggestions on how this has to be done and exactly what is meant by
unregulated is very dependent on where scores fish on the y axis,
but the intention is roughly to have the economy driven by free exchange in
competition,
right.
Scores have higher tendencies of believing the competition and free exchange
lead to better products and much more efficient allocation of resources.
Property rights covered by capitalism,
which basically state that what you own is what your own with reference to the
specific details of how a given society works allow people to profit from
resources that they own,
which they believe causes higher rates of innovation and distribution.
The top down hierarchy of capitalism they tend to believe is not necessarily
structured.
I'm privileged,
but opportunity and hard work.
The opportunity to climb the economic ladder causes people to work harder and
harder work rates,
as I said,
in their opinion,
a better workforce,
better products,
and better allocation of resources,
which creates an ideal society.
In standard capitalists theory.
For example,
an individual may own an area of land rich and iron.
The iron belongs to that individual,
but so did the burdens of extracting it.
The individual typically exchange something.
Usually nowadays currency for money,
equipment and payment for the miners,
a he or she will hire to extract it and then with the extracted iron we'll
typically sell it on the market in exchange for other things.
Again,
nowadays currency,
it's not also a straight forward as that.
However,
in the middle of the two for example,
ideologies exists such as a mutualism in which workers on the means of
production collectively but good.
They're still exchange on the free market.
There are a very important differences between the forest sides which had been
created here.
Typically they're referred to as the author Terrian left the authoritarian,
right.
The libertarian left and the libertarian right.
Each has a significantly different perspective on how the world works.
The left will criticize the right for bread molding and grocery stores.
While there are hungry outside,
the right will criticize a less for conditions which create bread lines and
hunger.
The bottom will criticize a top or being controlling and invasive.
The top will criticize and bottom for being inefficient and scattered within the
spectrum are all sorts of answers to all sorts of problems.
There are not always clear or easy answers to the problems of the world,
which has led to the political diversity that we see here.
Now having settled all of that,
I think the best way to navigate the compass is to position relatively well
understood politics.
Science.
With a large portion of my viewers being American,
we'll use American politics for now.
The two main parties of the United States are the Democrats and the Republicans,
also known as the Liberals and the Conservatives based off of other charts and
such things.
We'll put the liberals here and the Conservatives here for the averages.
They are,
as you can see,
relativity clothes but significantly distanced in the same quadrant.
To elaborate.
They both typically believe in a decent amount of government.
It's just a whole different expectations for what the government is and isn't
allowed to interfere with.
An obvious example is the economy which explains the gap and right to left with
reference to the entire chart here.
One could easily call both liberals and conservatives capitalists,
but liberals tend to favor more government programs and intervention and things
of that nature.
These two parties only represent about half the nation actually.
However many Americans identify as independents or unaffiliated with other
party.
For the majority of those people.
However,
this means they swing between issues placed on the party averages here.
Based off of that,
one could infer the probably over three fourths of American fit within this red
box here.
There are also some prominent third parties in the United States.
The two main ones are the Libertarians and the Greens will put the American
Libertarian Party here and the Green party here.
The Libertarian party is generally not comprised of extreme libertarians.
They don't quite fit into the bottom quadrant,
but they border closely.
The Greens are slightly less controlling to than liberals.
When it comes to government authority,
but government authority is necessary kids in,
and they're usually much more focused on government programs and things of that
nature.
To the point of bordering on mild socialism,
a very substantial portion of the United States population fits into the
authoritarian right quadrant.
And interestingly,
we can see that a miniature graph could be created within a top right quadrant.
Let's clot some very relevant leaders on here from this election and last
election to help clarify Donald Trump,
ted Cruz,
Barack Obama,
Hillary Clinton,
Bernie Sanders,
Gary Johnson,
Ron Paul,
and Jill Stein.
Again,
as you can see,
despite the differences between everyone here,
that all basically fit with an the top right quadrant.
You may disagree with that claim,
but because a huge portion of Americans are in the top right quadrant,
they wouldn't be electable if they weren't as well.
No.
A lot of graphs actually put,
for example,
Bernie Sanders and Jill Stein,
a left quadrants to put Ron Paul down towards,
and Arco capitalism will put Donald Trump right up next to Hitler.
So if you're going to be looking at these charts online,
be aware that exaggeration in bias are very common on them.
Let's plot some other ideologies here to gain a better understanding of what's
going on here.
We have the and Arco,
socialists and Arco.
Socialists typically favor the destruction of the state and replacing it with
horizontal electives,
which very instructor depending on specific ideology,
but the main ideology here is an article communism.
Here you'd have the anarcho capitalists moments you have here.
Also,
it will be that the state is unnecessary and our capitalists believe that people
are able to live in society and maintain the capitalist free market without the
knee of a state.
You have up here more Marxists thinking.
One of the main Marxist ideologies is Marxism,
Leninism,
which will place here.
Now this can be a bit trickier because traditionally Marxist Leninist believe is
strong workers.
State isn't necessary to overcome capitalism at first,
but then gradually the government should back off as the work has become more
anarchistic.
Others believe on holding onto a strong state in definitely,
which is responsible for directing what they see as the liberation of the
working class into socialist economics up here.
Also towards authoritarianism,
we can place fascism.
Fascism is typically about giving the reigns,
the state,
but economically fascist can be more divided.
Some are more socialists,
some are more capitalists,
so the average fits about here to match famous recent world leaders and
philosophers and such.
With this,
we can add Hitler,
Stalin,
George Washington,
Thomas Jefferson,
Noam Chomsky,
Milton Friedman,
and Margaret Thatcher.
I hope that this has given you a good sense of how all this fits together,
but there is a major problem with his chart.
The chart is pretty much strictly looking at level of government authority and
economic leaps.
It's not the greatest at looking at the intricacy of social philosophy and
policy.
Technically speaking,
an individual who is very socially liberal,
but we use in gay marriage,
feminism is pro choice,
et Cetera,
but a strong authoritarian government and complete free market.
Capitalism belongs here.
Likewise and individual who believes the anticommunist model of society is
ideal,
but is prolife antifeminist white nationalists who would fit around here.
Technically speaking,
person a was socially not identify with the far right person,
be with Sophie,
not identify with the far left,
but on this chart they're matched when outside of his chart they considered on
different ends of the spectrum,
so this chart is not perfect.
It's meant to be more general or introductory.
To really understand political differences.
You have to look at ideologies individually.
For more videos like this and videos on many other subjects,
we shouldn't take out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.
By the way,
fire of learning is on Facebook and now Instagram links of both are in the
description.
I plan to use social media to post things that I wouldn't really dedicate a
whole video to such as interesting facts and information or relevant updates to
the channel.
Yeah,
I've had a page for the channel on Facebook for a while now and I'll be honest,
I hate the Facebook page set up.
You go on your page and you're suddenly spammed with all these insights and tips
on how to function a page and just owning a page on there has definitely gotten
worse over the years.
But I will definitely try to use that in Instagram from now on.
So thank you again for watching.